hey oh you move your loving maniacs how
you doing right I know it's a little
early to get a spoiler video for Iron
Man 3 up but I'm gonna be gone this
weekend I wanted to do it before this
weekend so that's today and this is
gonna be a spoiler heavy video if you
haven't seen Iron Man 3 don't watch this
unless you really don't give a [ __ ]
about spoilers we're talking movie
breaking spoilers if you want to see my
Iron Man 3 review I have a spoiler free
Iron Man 3 review feel free to say it
right if you're still here you want [ __ ]
ruined for you so let's do it a lot of
people have said Jeremy do a spoiler
filled video on Iron Man 3 and they
really don't give a [ __ ] about 90% of
the spoilers in this movie they don't
care that Gweneth took fire juice and
she was kicking ass they don't care that
Killian was breathing fire like when
acally sees dragons and [ __ ] they don't
care what they really mean is one thing
Jeremy talked about the Mandarin so
we're gonna talk about the Mandarin so
in my review of Iron Man 3 I said
there's something in this movie that's
gonna divide the fans and people are
either gonna roll with it
or they're just not going to roll with
it I really meant the Mandarin why
because at first the Mandarin is awesome
you're like this guy's menacing and he's
like do you want it into your life or a
meaningful life you could be a winner in
the game a life feel like oh it's like
bin Laden with better rings get this guy
this guy is causing trouble he's bad
news and they find the Mandarin and
you're like the [ __ ] says the Mandarin
is just this actor this eccentric pill
popping drunk actor played by Ben
Kingsley which means Ben Kingsley was
awesome in this movie he was menacing
when he needed to be menacing and he was
some weirdo creep ass actor when he
needed to be that the Mandarin is an
actor the Mandarin is [ __ ] the
Mandarin was created by Guy Pearce to be
this really menacing figure so he could
put a face to all the bombings so the US
government could be like oh we need to
find that guy so they just be chasing
their tail really smart when you think
about it when I saw it I was like that's
a good plot point I can see that like
James Bond or something doing that to an
iconic character in comic-book lore it's
a little different I have to be like
well is it good for the movie yeah it's
a really smart play for a villain to do
in a movie that being said [ __ ] in
the oatmeal of all the hardcore Ironman
Mandarin fans probably a mistake if
you're going to do something like this
at least replace the fake Mandarin with
a real Mandarin like Batman Begins
spoiler alert for Batman Begins Ra's al
Ghul dies you're like well I guess
that's the end of him and then Liam
Neeson's like pluses Raza
we move on and you're like holy [ __ ]
he's Ra's al Ghul and it works because
you're like yet checklist on everything
Ra's al Ghul yeah and he fits him better
than the last cut yes he is Ra's al Ghul
and that blows my mind that I didn't
actually catch it which makes me feel
like an idiot it worked in that in this
movie that had no replacement it's just
he is [ __ ] the character that you
guys love who is the Mandarin is just
not here and now people are gonna
beeline it to a phrase that guy Pierce
says in the movie he's like you're
looking for the Mandarin I am the
Mandarin but I never actually took that
as I am the character the Mandarin in
comic-book lore translated to screen I
took that as well conceptually speaking
if you're looking for the guy who's
behind everything I am him so
technically speaking metaphorically
speaking
I am the Mandarin I guess it's not like
the Ra's al Ghul thing in Batman Begins
it is different it would have been
really cool if they did have a
businessman in this movie who was
Killians character but wasn't Killian
who when he was like I am the Mandarin
you're like wait a minute
holy [ __ ] that's actually the Mandarin
that's awesome but in no point this
movie was all like Guy Pearce is clearly
the Mandarin that's nuts so it didn't
convince me so I took it as a
metaphorical thing I still do because I
think if the concept and intent was uh
we're supposed to reveal right there guy
appears as the Mandarin that's just
delusional at that point cuz he's not
guy Pierce is the Mandarin and Iron Man
3 like your parents were Santa Claus
when you were a kid spoiler alert for
people who believe in Santa Claus you
had a face to the concept you're like oh
Santa Claus this guy comes down the
chimney and puts presents under the tree
and he's real then you find out who's
Santa Claus isn't real the phrase is
Santa Claus isn't real Santa Claus
doesn't exist the phrase is not your
parents or Santa Claus her dad is not a
guy who hangs out in the North Pole with
elves and reindeer and maybe he is but
if he is he has a lot more secrets than
you want to know about but he's not he's
not that he's not the person that Santa
Claus has been made to be they're doing
the actions that they say this character
is doing but that doesn't make them the
character it just makes them parents
relying for holiday fun but still it's
[ __ ] Santa Claus doesn't exist he's
not real like the Mandarin doesn't exist
he's not real guy Pierce is not the
Mandarin he's just a guy who's behind it
all again Batman metaphor but I like
those movies he's like the Joker causing
all this trouble but you don't actually
see him face to face and then when
Batman gets there Batman bust in the
door he's like dude you find out that
Joker is just some hippie burnout in his
mom's basement Joker's like
ooh this is awkward my name is Bob April
Fool's I would be like that's stupid I
would hate the Dark Knight if they did
that then Eric Roberts is like and
looking from the Joker I am The Joker I
get it fans hold on to their things
their characters their Lord that they
love when doing this movie they had to
know that they had to know like fans
we're gonna get backlash I got to know
when suspicions started to arrive so the
question was asked um do you think fans
are gonna be mad who was the guy who was
like yeah and I don't roll at the deal
roll if they trust me I know fans trust
me they're not they don't hold onto
comic book lore that much they don't
care about the Mandarin well apparently
they do because the exact reaction I
thought would happen is happening and if
you are leaning towards the argument of
well if the Mandarin is an actor in the
movie then maybe he's not the Mandarin
problem is the Mandarin is in the moving
instead of being everything that people
know the Mandarin to be badass martial
artist has his crazy rings alien
technology and all that [ __ ] he's an
actor from Beverly Hills that's what he
is
that'll ruffle some feathers so yeah
that's my take on all the spoilers in
the movie and by all I mean the one that
people really want to know about other
than that I thought it was interesting
that Tony Stark gets surgery on his
heart you know he doesn't have to wear
the Iron Man thing anymore
Robert Downey jr. said he doesn't know
if he's going to come back for another
Iron Man or Avengers movie but you know
he's going to come back he's gonna get a
[ __ ] Dillion dollars from this movie's
gonna buy two houses in Malibu he's
gonna be like I could go for doing that
again sure yeah I'm in like I said in my
review and I stand by it I still had a
lot of fun with the movie I enjoyed the
[ __ ] out of it I'm just saying they
probably shouldn't have done this and I
understand if you hate it because they
did my question to you is the Mandarin
situation do you think it was smart did
you roll with it were you one of the
fans who was like uh-uh
no whatever you think comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you seen here and you want to see more
click right here to see more
you